okay all right I'm surrounded by my
hair's just so it was just blue tonic
Rick Santorum what are your thoughts on
the Iran nuclear deal I'm guessing you
love it cuz it's Obama whatever he does
you're good violated the first principle
you don't negotiate with terrorists and
we negotiated with a terrorist
organization Reagan moon at well you
don't negotiate with terrorists we've
negotiated we did negotiate with
terrorists and that your boyfriend no we
didn't go through the terrace Reagan
never negotiate negotiate we can admit
it on the air ago she ate with
terrorists what about iran-contra that
wasn't negotiating matter that was
cutting a deal regular negotiating with
terrorists he also cut and ran when the
bombing happened in Beirut in 83 George
Bush's vice present went over there and
said this will not stand at whatever and
then we caught and ran yes Raja dad he
was wrong Reagan was wrong sir oh my god
this was a relatively new threat way
back then and and you know radical Islam
was on it was emergent during that time
the hope and he had it look he had a
different he had a different fish to fry
ed he had the Soviet Union and he was
trying to destroy the whole country
that's what was a tension there has to
be just terrorists the whole country of
a red all those like it's not who the
country is it's who's running the
country alright and and the people
running the country are is a death cult
they're a group of radical Muslims Shia
Islamists who are more concerned about
the hereafter than they are to here and
now any problem will with with what the
policy's been over these only years that
we've been negotiating this rotten
treaty which is going to give the more
regime 150 billion dollars to spend on
terrorism all this time we have
hesitated to help the people of Iran
fight this regime which you thought
which is what we ended up doing what
in 2009 the Green Revolution occurred
and the United States of America said
nothing he absolutely passed on doing
anything to support that wouldn't we be
doing doing see okay guys all that time
say Obama's such a destructed this and
then the next question but what would
you do I'm not
fight Isis differently I would you drop
I here to prove that I broke the map
take the mallet boy he's not allowing
this answer for you in terms of cutting
and running from Beirut which was the
right thing to do Ronald Reagan learned
a lesson and he started what they call
the Reagan doctrine which is helping
people fight the tyrants who are the
enemies of the United States right who's
fighting Isis who's fighting I always go
back to go back to Iran the mullah
regime is a terrorist regime who
represses their own people we there any
number of groups there we could have
been supported you guys would agree that
Isis and Iran are the enemy right great
they're MOCA enemy so who's the worst
enemy because I guess by the Reagan
doctrine we should be supporting the
other so if it's Iran we should be
supporting Isis look in the Middle East
you cannot you can't I mean we learned
this Iran floor you cannot defeat Sunni
jihadism without having Sunnis on side
I've done a lot of reporting on Syria
for four years I've seen the conspiracy
theories devolved from a point of oh
you're backing Assad because you support
Israel now it is the United States
prefers the Shia not just of Iraq but
also Iran they want to work with the
Revolutionary Guard Corps which by the
way bill has built sectarian militias in
Syria that are burning people alive just
like Isis again we don't see it on the
nightly news doesn't mean it's not
taking place not be supporting Sunnis in
Iraq just - that's the point he's making
we shouldn't be supporting Iran at
anything we sir particularly shouldn't
be supporting Iran as they as they their
wages sectarian war and try to create
dominator the only ones who are doing
our dirty work against they shouldn't
know there's lots of groups under fire
in league fight against the right or
regime like these chronicles like
they're currently like oh the Arab of
the Sunnis in the Anbar province they
usually do how about them
how about how about the where are they
there are the sorry the beluche there's
more Kurds in Iran than there
are in Iraq any we could have helped any
of these people and said we sign an
agreement that legitimate Isis these
mullahs who hate us so what's going on
with your marijuana bill
the I am very proud that that I know
Rick just immediately on this that we
believe in states rights we believe in
personal responsibility believe in
doctor-patient relationships we leave in
making sure that you have a limited
government and a maximum of individual
freedom well that means that you should
let people smoke marijuana
it's all do we believe in our
fundamental principles we've been
talking about all these years and I
forced the issue I'm very proud to say
for the first time we got through the
Congress a bill that permits people at
least to use medical marijuana if
they're suffering have a doctor be able
to prescribe it in states where they
have already legalized it
so my bill just said if a state
legalizes the medical use of marijuana
the federal government can't step in and
supersede the State Fair unfair up CNN
and the Republican National Committee to
exclude Carly Fiorina from their next
debate
are they really excluding her or well in
a sense the RNC has given up
responsibility for allowing protrusion
who's gonna be on that debate stage
they've allowed the network's to make
the decision so if someone came in
second last time like Senator Santorum
they can't even get on the main stage
because the network's decide however
they want to do it the party is almost
disappear with my polling right they do
it by a polling that the network rise in
the polls so she did rise she may make
the second debate in Simi Valley she had
a pretty solid showing according a lot
of activists so we'll see
I mean she's someone Carson Trump
Fiorina they're seen as outsiders and
this in a lot of ways whenever you
travel around you see this is the year
of the outsider people want that kind of
person on the Republican side it makes
it harder even if you have a blue-collar
message you think must be energized like
you who know how government works when
Donald Trump says things like I would
slap a 35% tax on Ford as if a president
can unilaterally let yeah you're not the
CEO of our country yes thank you
yes yeah it drives us crazy okay 10
years after Hurricane Katrina are we any
more prepared for a natural disaster of
that magnitude well I bet you we are to
a certain degree I mean they did they
built up some levees there didn't they
I'm hoping yeah we should
[ __ ] tons of money down there I must
have done something right can't all be
for beads the government's going to be
doing a good job well then what but you
can trust the guy you do think the
government has a role in disaster relief
don't you yes I do
okay so FEMA which didn't work well
under Bush seems to be working better
under Obama I hope so
well good okay wendy is the media
tougher on female political candidates I
think there's a different standard for
female political candidates and I think
my race certainly demonstrated that as a
woman a divorced woman with two children
I went through a very different type of
scrutiny about that then a male
candidate would do and I think it's part
and parcel of what happens to women in
politics and when it does happen I think
it's important that we call it for what
it is because a lot of times people
respond to that they don't even
necessarily think consciously that
they're responding to negative messaging
that's succeeding in that way and when
you bring them present to it and they
consider it it really I think does make
a powerful difference and more women
candidates
okay is there any significance the
Cornel West's endorsement of Bernie
Sanders well that with let me ask this
about Bernie Sanders I mean he has huge
crowds you cheer outs the media doesn't
cover that nearly the way they do Donald
Trump also I noticed all Republicans are
able to dismiss Bernie Sanders with one
word socialist like case closed I don't
have to argue anymore he's a socialist
social Social Security is socialism but
would you campaign against that well if
what I think Chris Matthews questioned
to Deborah Wasserman Schultz was really
the operative question what's the
difference between a socialist and a
Democrat and to the state my
understanding she says not answered even
though she's been asked multiple times
and they and the truth is that the
Democratic Party is basically a
socialist party these well well what is
our the left America and every moment
you tell me the difference was there a
Democratic Socialist well I wish the
Democrats were social okay well okay
every modern country is a quasi
socialist country including the United
States and again you would not vote to
repeal Social Security would you and if
you wouldn't then you are also quasi
social just because they're the programs
or the Veterans Administration is just
because the government does certain
functions that we believe should be
socialized doesn't mean that we're a
socialist I mean socially for example I
mean the fact that we provide for a
common defense and that we fund the
defense funds that make us socialist no
because the government isn't of course
the money the military old wouldn't
become socialism and the Republicans
haven't reached that level but to the
degree that we support social you know
it's real socialism is the fact that
every year the Pentagon tells Congress
not to build weapons they say we don't
need them we can't use them we literally
have no place to put them and Congress
still makes them because it's a jobs
program in their district that's
socially
like for welfare anytime you buy a
weapon system that you don't absolutely
need for the defense you're doing a
disservice to the people by the way
Bernie Sanders we worked with Bernie he
was he's a nice guy guys guys this guy
is running a real campaign see he's
connected I have almost every college
student I encounter is for Sanders it's
unbelievable it's about tone what is the
policy difference between Hillary
Clinton's between Hillary Clinton that's
one great thing about Bernie Sanders
he's forced her to move to the last
thing he was really pushing for is
single-payer health care system he's
talking which really supported them but
you know what I think that he has helped
make the Democratic candidates
altogether a better group because he is
speaking to something that is really in
people's hearts and minds in this
country they are so frustrated with
income inequality they are so frustrated
with wage stagnation they're so
frustrated watch beaches lands I talk
about the same yeah but you probably
have a different solution people
actually believe it Bernie Sanders will
put a lot of these walls not what
burning hooks in prison they don't
believe it when Hillary Clinton says it
yeah okay
Thank You panel you were very very
entertaining I appreciate you coming out
you